chaque année arles organise son festival
de la photo les plus grands noms de la
photo ils sont exposés avec cette année
des photos venues d'ailleurs si je puis
dire puisqu'il s'agit de 500 clichés
prêté par la nasa autour de l'espace
photo de l'espace réalisé par depuis 15
ans le festival d'arles fait beaucoup
pour la photographie même si certains
autochtones et selon le témoignage d'un
confrère trouve que c'est le moment où
les fadas aux lentilles prennent
possession de la cité si les arlésiens
ont le sens de la formule ils ont aussi
un festival qui pendant un mois fait de
leur ville la capitale de la
photographie
les points forts des rencontres
c'est d'abord 27 expositions et c'est
énorme ce sont des soirées au théâtre
antique avec des grands sujets comme la
nasa le 90e anniversaire de lartigue les
trottoirs boisé de c'est-à-dire
l'argentine et ses tangos
mais ce sont aussi une trentaine de
stages qui regroupe plus de 450
étudiants qui viennent du monde entier
des colloques des encours des
chaussettes en coton sérieuse dans la
rue où tout le monde de se voir ces
photos là alors ça c'est c'est le
triomphe d'allah parmi cette débauche
d'image notre confrère libération
présentera quelques unes des photos
qu'il produit signé par william klein
depardon xavier langon françoise huguier
etc
il ya 230 photos c'est tous des photos
qui ont été commandés par le journal
donc on a fait un choix un peu qui
correspond à la politique photos de
libération c'est à dire de demander à
des photographes qu'on aime bière soit
parce qu'ils sont sympas soit parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup de talent de se
comporter comme des auteurs des
signatures de journal comme
les signatures de textes
par le 84 honorera le célèbre l'arctique
et d'autres photographes moins connue
a fait depuis 15 ans c'est un moyen de
l'exprimer ma vie personnelle de
regarder les choses qui sont importantes
en images avant je faisais souvent je
travaille avec le court mais c'était
plus voilées s'étaient plus métaphorique
et elle même attend je fais et les
portraits maintenant je fais le mélange
est ce que vous pensez du développement
de la photo en cinquante ans on est
passé brusquement
d'un espace d'art populaire très très
sain
plein de scènes
à travail qui ont envie une envie qu'on
les photographes de devenir des
intellectuels
en 50 ans la photo ainsi pris de
l'altitude et sous le titre déclic dans
l'espace on pourra voir des photos
inédites prises par les astronautes
c'est drôle et
une sélection de 175 mille photos qui
font rêver même ceux qui volent dans la
lune et qui prouve que certains
photographes ont aussi les toffes des
héros